la pandémie du cofidis n'a pas fait
officiellement 5 millions de morts dans
le monde mais il pourrait être en
réalité trois fois plus élevé c'est ce
qu'affirme une dernière étude publiée
par le magazine britannique the
economist
pour en finir avec cette épidémie
mondiale la pilule anti qu'au guide est
très attendue notamment le géant
pharmaceutique pfizer a d'ailleurs
demandé hier l'autorisation en urgence
aux états unis pour son traitement une
pilule aux résultats prometteurs on en
parle tout de suite avec thomas bonnet
en direct de washington bonsoir trauma
est les essais cliniques de ce
traitement antiviral donne apparemment
beaucoup d'espoir pour la suite et en
prime il est plutôt facile à prendre
oui c'est un traitement proposé par
pfizer qui s'appelle le pack solide et
qui est présenté par l'entreprise comme
un traitement très efficace
pfizer a publié ses résultats
intermédiaires et affiche le chiffre de
le nombre de 89 % d'efficacité pour
prévenir le risque d'hospitalisation ou
les décès pour les adultes à risque des
chiffres des données dont se félicite le
pdg fait de pfizer évidemment écouter
l'efficacité écrasante atteinte dans
notre étude clinique sur le pacs l'eau
vide et sa capacité à aider à sauver des
vies et maintenir les gens hors de
l'hôpital s'il est autorisé souligner le
rôle crucial que les thérapies
antivirales peuvent jouer dans la
bataille contre le coc vite 19
alors concrètement ce traitement de
pfizer est un traitement qui doit être
pris rapidement après l'apparition des
premiers symptômes et c'est un
traitement relativement important
puisqu'il y à un total de 30 comprimés à
avaler dans une période de cinq jours
dont à 10 pilules de ritonavir qui est
un médicament qui est déjà utilisée
contre le virus du sida alors tout cas
la maison blanche semble croire très
fortement ce traitement puisque selon
les informations du washington post 10
millions de traitements pourraient être
prochainement commandé par les autorités
américaines pour une somme totale de 5
milliards de dollars il faudra donc à
d'abord attendre l'approbation de
l'agencé américaine des médicaments
merci thomas bonnin non pardonnez-moi ya
encore une petite relance la mise sur le
marché prochaine avec des premières
pilules anti qu'ovide c'est aussi cette
bataille qui se prépare en coulisses
entre peur et msd
oui il ya la concurrence pour le géant
pfizer puisque merck propose une autre
traitement qu'ils appellent le menu pire
aviram traitement qui a déjà été
autorisé au royaume uni et dont la f10 l
agence américaine des médicaments doit
se prononcer d'ici le 30 novembre
prochain alors on sait que washington en
a déjà commandé 3,1 millions de ces
traitements proposés par merck il ya une
différence de prix entre les deux
puisque le traitement proposé par merck
coûte 700 $ par traitement et ses 500
dollars pour celui de pfizer alors
l'émergence de ces traitements
intervient au moment où il ya un certain
nombre de critiques notamment de la part
des ong qui travaillent en afrique sur
les profits engrangés par ses
laboratoires pharmaceutiques alors même
que le vaccin n'est pas accessible à
tous les habitants de tous les pays on
sait qu'il y avait eu évidemment des
discussions pour lever les brevets sur
la vaccination snap finalement pas
abouti alors peut-être c'est une forme
de réponse on a appris que par exemple
preiser allait faciliter l'accès à ces
traitements pour les pays en
développement voici je peux vous dire
merci définitivement tom abonnés en
direct de washington